avant même que les répétitions
commencent il y avait des
positionnements déjà pré établies
c'est-à-dire que telle mise de
l'exposition ici et puis on voit que
certaines candidates notamment les
favorites sur les réseaux sociaux sur
les journaux etc sont constamment milieu
font des ouvertures
donc on voit qu'il ya des
positionnements qui sont qui sont
réfléchies et qui sont préétablis avant
même que finalement ils nous connaissent
d'accord oui j'aimerais juste je pense
qu'au bout sur ce que miss france le
comité s'en fout que ce soit pierre paul
est en revanche plus alors qu'on appelle
pudiquement
chaque année la polémique revient c'est
toujours la même pourquoi est ce qu'ils
donnent pas de pouvoirs publics avec un
vote uniquement un public puisque on
sait que s'il ya un jury c'est vrai et
au fait que le jury bas orienté
forcément le spectacle bord et pourquoi
il faut pas ça vous vous êtes dans la
production vous êtes dans vos
connaissent un peu la production oui
pourquoi est ce que à quoi est-ce que le
vol était de la miss france qui
représente celle d'un plat préféré des
français n'est pas élue uniquement pas
plus glissant alors
que vous faites partie de la production
non mais j'ai dit c'est l'élection de
miss avons
donc j'ai vu comment ça se passe et de
l'intérieur et je suis d'accord avec
vous il n'ya pas de triche et en plus
quand tu vois la personne en face ne
s'échappe pas le même 10 manca partage
pas la vision qu'on ne voit pas ça mais
ça réglerait le problème c'est le vote
était uniquement ouverts au public
n'aurait plus de suspicion de triche
alors je vais vous dire non mais c'est
aussi un show et forcément on arrive de
production produire un show voilà donc
conduire à chaud avec des artistes qui
viennent et qu'ils sont nombreux du jury
voilà donc forcément voilà 50 50 on
s'est dit que ça pouvait être bien voilà
je pense que oui mais je suis guéri a
même piqué revient sur vire il pourrait
y avoir le jury qui a qui à titre
consultatif moi je pense que ça pourrait
leur arriver forcément se pose toujours
la question comme dans sa question sur
la ou quand à une oreillette oui le
producteur pourra dire ça serait bien
qu'un tel événement je vous dis je n'ai
jamais alors là je voudrais je dis que
forcément celui qu en tout cas depuis
que la production sebban idier endemol
franchement je vous dise les deux
dernières franchement ça chez les jets
n'ont jamais dit que sa rivale aer bull
aurait dit je joue le rythme et aucun
intérieur gilles ce qui pose problème et
je suis entièrement d'accord avec vous
c'est la sélection finale et là vous
avez des jeunes femmes qui sont écartés
soit parce qu'elles ne correspondent pas
à des länder physique on voit la fin
soit par la région la région de laquelle
elle vient est trop petit et n'intéresse
pas que ça c'est le problème de la
sélection finale c'est le problème aussi
des votes oui
chacun couple exactement il ya des vols
des régions qui votent boucler
le renforcement de banide j'ai pas ce
qu'on fait souvent la fixette sur
l'élection a dit que les modes et aux
grands de mol qui qui qui a lieu au mois
de décembre il ya aussi tous les comités
régionaux les élections dame ça n'a rien
à voir l'avez vous devez vous d'autres
non mais j'ai pas dis ça je dis juste
que je vous donne un exemple suicide et
100 m2 dont l'élection de miss nord pas
de calais 2019 qu'iter une grande
favorite parmi les miss elle s'appelle
mehdi pinte sauf que médicaux un jour
mais qui partent c'est son nom a mis
quatre jours avant l'élection elle est
exclue du concours au motif qu'elle a
participé à qu'elle a participé pardon à
un concours concurrent or elle n'avait
jamais caché qu'elle avait participé à
ce concours concurrent et son cas avait
même été acceptée par la délégation
régionale or comme par hasard c'est
l'année où en 2010 9 annabelle varane la
fille de du rafale varane le champion du
monde de foot est élue miss nord pas de
calais dont c'est la vocation finisseur
mérite d'être jours avant l'élection
aurait pas de procès
elle adore donc je veux dire pas durer
toujours mais c'est vrai que ça faut
s'aimer mois de cet impôt d'un film moi
j'ai rien contre al amel van tan mieu
manière il a essayé mais ça pose
question